be the leader you wish you had become a
student of leadership study it read
about it watch things about it practice
it every day you know like be a parent
you know like join the movement means
i'm gonna take care of my team sometimes
i'm in a leader leadership position and
sometimes i'm not and it doesn't matter
i'm to practice leadership if i'm a
salesperson
you know if i'm if i work at the if i
work at uh the check-in counter of an
airline i'm going to take care of the
people i work with i'm going to take
care of the customers as if as if
they're my family you know like practice
leadership learn about it study it
because i do these things because i i
recognize i'm just a piece of a jigsaw
puzzle you know it's one of the reasons
i wanted to come talk to you on camera
it's because you know when we do a
jigsaw puzzle the first thing you do is
lean the picture of the the box against
the wall and then you start
putting the pieces together to build
that picture
my job in this movement i'm the guy who
points at the box right i'm the one
who's pointing at the picture pointing
the picture maybe pointing out a couple
of the pieces and where they go
but i need
lots of people to join me we need lots
of people to join us
who say i have a piece of the puzzle i'm
willing to lead this way i'm willing to
abandon milton friedman ideals and and
do something bigger something more
follow that you know live with an
infinite mindset lead with an infinite
mindset and put their piece down and say
how can i help build that vision we
we need the army and so
how people can engage in the movement is
actually practicing all the stuff more
than anything else that's what we need
need motivation catch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
simon sonic and my take on his top 10
rules to success enjoy
rule number two be a follower the best
leaders are actually the best followers
in what ways what do you mean
the best leaders
never think that they're the final that
the buck stops with them they always
believe that they're in service to
something bigger than themselves and
even if that leader uh that person in
leadership position gets to the tippy
top of whatever organization they still
feel that they're subordinate to
something even bigger right so
uh
uh the pope
does still thinks that he's in service
to something bigger than than him right
a ceo of a visionary organization
feels that they are still beholden to
and
and following a vision bigger than them
so the best leader is actually the best
followers even if they're at the highest
levels of of the organization they're
still in service right it may not be to
a person but to a cause to accomplish an
idea a vision
whatever it is there's still some sort
of something that they're beholden to
and they're devoted to and they're in
service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and um
not to belabor the marine point but
uh
you know marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good followership so
for example there when you go through
ocs officer candidates
school
selection
when somebody's a for a task you know
chosen to be the leader of that group
for that task
the the marines are watching the others
as well so they're looking to see that
everybody's contributing ideas they're
looking to see that that leader takes in
those ideas but is decisive and
and they're looking to see that the the
members of the group if their idea isn't
picked they still give their all
to see that the the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and see what
they can do as opposed to going i told
you i should have gotten my way
right i was right or sabotaging because
their idea didn't get picked so they go
all in so so good followership
is is as important as good leadership
that that we we respect that that um
when a decision is made we will we will
give our blood sweat and tears to see
that the decision our leaders have made
will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal rule number three lead
by example one thing make them work
together um uh i shared incentives is
also a part of thing usually all we do
is give individual incentives which
means we're only incentivizing behavior
to work individually
um uh
and by the way incentives don't always
have to be financial it can be just
recognition and reward you know catch
people doing things right so when you
see people helping each other and
sharing call it out publicly you know
compliment publicly criticize privately
um in front of the rest of the team
um um give people promotions when
there's a behavior that you want to
promote like like teaming um um but also
ask people to solve problems together
and
and thank them together and if one
person comes to you and complains i'm
doing all the work you say well
why don't you find out what maybe
they're struggling maybe they're like we
have to push
push back
and also i think the most important
thing is leading by example
asking for help i mean when the leader
acts like they know everything and they
have all the answers then all it's doing
is telling everybody else you better
know everything and have all the answers
because that's how you're going to get
ahead here and so i think one of the
most difficult things for anybody in a
leadership position
to get comfortable with is is saying i
don't know or i need help or can
somebody help me or can you do this with
me
um i love
working i love teaming with folks on on
my team
it doesn't matter what the rank
structure is bring in someone junior
let's work together um
even if all they're doing is poking
holes you know do you think this is good
no i think you can better okay let me
try again
um so i think i think demonstrating the
behavior that we want is a big part of
it rule number four be humble heck man
i've disagreed with my own ideas you
know i've been pig-headed and dogmatic
about this is the way we got to go and
everybody is wonderful and and
kind of like falls apart and just like
okay yeah i kind of screwed the pooch on
that one yeah but i take accountability
yeah you know or we find in the middle
somebody goes
hey if we do this we can probably be
more successful when we pivot
there's there has to be at the
decision-making ranks there has to be a
humility that the ideas don't always
have to come from me right bob galer the
fifth chief master sergeant of the air
force has the best definition of
humility i've ever heard he said don't
confuse humility with meekness
humility is being open to the ideas of
others
so you know it's not about like
oh shucks that's not humility you know
you and i know some remarkable leaders
people of great power and authority
and they have huge egos yes you know
they know they're good and they don't
mind talking about how good they are but
when somebody says hey i got an idea
they lean in like they're little kids
they go let's hear it
you know i'm looking at some of the
photographs on your wall and some of the
folks that i know here they have an
insatiable curiosity for ideas and even
though they're unbelievably accomplished
if you have something to share with them
they want to talk about it they want
they want to hear about it that's
humiliating to me
you know so it's not this you know it's
not me it's you know
how self-confidence is a good thing
thinking you're better than everyone
else that's unhealthy that's good yeah
you know thinking you're good
is healthy thinking you're better than
others is unhealthy
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five nurture
relationships what are your thoughts
around courage how do people um get the
courage to
to play the long game to not the long
game it's the infinite game because a
long game could be five years right true
yeah this is forever
uh how do people build that everything
that we're talking about in the infinite
game is really really really really hard
it is so much easier to build a company
based on short-term ambitions than it is
an infinite cause it just is right it's
also fun
right until it's not
um
less inspiring but sometimes sometimes
fun right hitting a goal feels good
right
um
it's much easier to just hire and fire
people
frequently higher fast fire fast as to
hiring slowly and and firing slowly
because we we try and take care of our
people as best we can it's just it's
hard to build teams all of that stuff we
talked about leadership like what am i
supposed to do to build a trusting team
well
i wish i could give you a list of five
things it's really really hard to be a
parent
it's much easier to be an uncle or an
aunt or not have kids
right it's hard
right so why do it you know it's fun and
and exciting to be to try and beat our
competitors you know
but to have to face our own weaknesses
every day
oh
that's exhausting you know existential
flexibility i'd rather not i just would
rather not
you know so
so the reason this takes courage to
completely change our mindset a about
the game that we're actually players in
um and how we want to approach these
things and do we want to shift our
mindset and our organizations to prepare
for the infinite game to be organized
for the infinite game
it takes courage because we're going to
be swimming upstream in a world that is
very finite driven you know the
pressures on us are overwhelming from
wall street or our own egos or from
internal incentive structures or our
bosses whatever it is
the pressures are overwhelming for us to
play the finite game
and so how do you stand up to massive
external pressure courage
and courage is something that comes from
relationships
you know it's external
a a world famous trapeze artist would
never attempt a brand new death defying
act for the first time without a net
they would never do it so why do we
think that we could do something
difficult without external support too
um i've had the opportunity to meet real
heroes people who've risked their lives
to save the lives of others with the
belief that they were going to die
and they didn't
and when asked why did you do it they
all say something similar which is they
would have done it for me it's external
and so we have to have
we have to take the time to foster and
take care of people around us to nurture
our relationships because when we're
going to be doing something difficult
when we're going to be swimming upstream
when we're going to be innovating and
and and
and doing something different
there are days we're going to doubt
ourselves there are days we're going to
get knocked in our ass there are days
that storms are going to rise and we
have to have people who say
i got you back
you need to do this
we need you the world needs this keep
going
i believe in you you know
um
and so courage courage comes from from
not only our willingness to do that for
others but then their willingness to do
it for us and if we commit ourselves to
a just cause and we're willing to to do
those things then
you know the great thing is we take a
lot of people with us
and change the world for the better
and isn't that sort of the point of an
infinite life to leave this world in
better shape than we found it to leave
the companies that we work for in better
shape than when we started to leave our
families stronger and better capable
than than
what they can do without us you know
isn't isn't that what it means to live
an infinite life that we can live
literally live on beyond our own lives
rule number six teach self-reliance we
take accountability away from people and
we don't even realize it so we're
actually destroying people's confidence
or ability to make decisions because we
keep answering their questions or making
decisions for them i had a boss many
years ago
one of the best leaders i ever had peter
and tomagio
and
he wouldn't answer a single question i
asked it drove me absolutely nuts hey
peter you know what should i do well
what do you think we should do
well i i'm i think we should do this he
goes well you should give that a try
then
you know or he would just ask me
questions he goes well have you
considered this i went
no he goes well maybe think about that
you know but he would never tell me the
answer he'd always tell me the
parameters
um what he told me was self-reliance it
was the most valuable lesson i probably
ever ever learned
um very often you know somebody will
come and say you know should we go with
blue or green
i'll go with green well we just answered
the question once i go with the one you
think we should go with
what should we do here make the decision
you think is the right decision to make
you know and then let them make the
decision and when we give people
accountability the amazing thing is they
rise to it yeah but we keep taking the
accountability because we keep answering
all the questions so there's a very easy
lesson for everyone here is
um stop replying to all the emails that
you're getting while you're away
right like i know what happens you know
in every break or
right now
uh
you know there's an email that says you
know should we go with this one or that
one and you're replying
and in every break you're going to reply
to all your emails and tell people your
opinion of what you think they should do
versus saying
i'm going away for a few days for this
conference so i can learn to be a better
leader um hold down the fort while i'm
away
if there's an emergency
figure it out
you know
um or only call me if you absolutely do
not know the answer
um and stop replying to all the emails
and they now have to work you're giving
away
uh responsibility one of the reasons
they don't take responsibility is
because they don't give it to them rule
number seven be in service how do you
develop
self-confidence we're kind of going off
here now but
this is a topic i'm really passionate
about right now i believe uh self-doubt
is one of the biggest killers to
anyone's dreams yeah so how does someone
develop
self-confidence
and sustain it with the ever-going
changes and stresses and uncertainties
that always come up once you reach a
certain level there's a new uncertainty
no so i think it's ironic that we call
it self-confidence
because i don't for one think it comes
from the inside
i think our self-confidence comes from
the outside
right you mean that's the wrong way of
going about it or you think that's where
it comes from in general
the we are being misdirected by the name
when we say build your self-confidence
that's the instruction is saying go
inside
look inside oneself
but i think that's i think that's i
think that's a false direction
children aren't born self-confident
their confidence is built
from their parents
and their friends and their teachers
where they're rewarded when they do well
and they're
pushed
when they fail
when they can do better simply you know
we know this that simply telling kids
that they're great all the time actually
doesn't build self-confidence actually
does the total opposite right right
um
and i for one
i can tell you my in my own experience
my own self-confidence um
uh a hundred percent comes from the
relationships that i have
um it's not some deep internal fortitude
you know a a world famous trapeze artist
is not gonna
try a brand new death defying act for
the first time without a net
so
it's the people in my life
it's it's when when i do doubt myself
that somebody says
you got this
when somebody says
i believe in you
when somebody says no matter what
happens whether it succeeds or fails i'm
going to be by your side
that's when i have the confidence to do
difficult things wow right i don't have
some natural battery that i that that
just
right you know that that to me is
bravado yeah i don't know about
self-confidence
you know
you know
being a huge risk taker
is not an indication of self-confidence
to me you know
jumping out of a plane and jumping out
of a plane with a parachute or two
different things right right um
to me self-confidence is measured
and there should be a degree of of of
doubt
um but but i i think true
self-confidence belief in oneself and
belief in one's cause you know i could
not do the things that i'm doing
and i would not have the strength
to have made the sacrifices that i've
made or continue to wake up on a daily
basis to drive to spread this message
if i were alone
and so
when we talk about building one
self-confidence i think the mistake that
we make is that we look inside i think
the reality is we're trying to build our
self-confidence we should be looking to
our friends we should be nursing our
relationships when i'm looking to build
my self-confidence the question is who
around me do i need to take care of
you know
the way we build our self-confidence is
by helping somebody else build theirs
right it's an act we will build our
confidence with an act of service rule
number eight implement reviews depending
on the size of the organization
obviously um uh
it's very common um that other team
members will go to the leader and say we
don't want to work with that person i
mean that that's usually a big highlight
you know
that's frequent um
you can tell in meetings very often if
somebody
is domineering
but i'm also a great fan of peer reviews
quite frankly
the the army rangers dealt with this
they called them spotlight rangers
when when candidates were going through
ranger school um they had to in the past
they had this issue where these very
talented ranger candidates and the team
and the instructors loved them
so they looked like they were great
candidates the problem is as soon as the
spotlight was turned off
they were horrible people
so leadership didn't know
and so they implemented peer reviews so
now you have to be good at your job your
instructor has to like you and your
colleagues have to like you your your
your and so
um and by like i mean respect and you
you know you you're seen as a team
player and help each other out so um if
all you're doing is reviewing annually
someone's performance
that's insufficient there needs to be
regular feedback mechanisms um
and there needs to be an open
open dialogue and peer review 360 review
where you all come into a room and you
get to give each other feedback in real
time
but yeah it's probably because there
aren't enough metrics rule number nine
take responsibility for people what is
your advice for somebody that's in a
company that they they don't have an
infinite minded culture
don't
don't be there no don't try and
influence that which you cannot
influence don't control that which you
cannot control
you know an infinite mindset means
that is something i can't do but i can
influence and take care of the people to
the left of me and to the right of me i
can take care of the people who work for
me i can even take care of the person i
work for sometimes we have a toxic boss
not because they're bad but because we
don't understand the pressure they're
under sometimes to simply exhibit
empathy to our boss you know hey boss
you were really harsh on us today
everything all right what's going on i'm
worried about you you know um i'm here
like we can we can succeed together i'm
we're here to help you you know if we're
no matter where we are inside an
organization
leadership is not about rank or
authority leadership is taking
responsibility for the people around us
and so any anybody on any team at any
rank at any level can be a leader
the first choice is that we have to want
to be a dear friend of mine lieutenant
general george flynn from the marine
corps said the first criterion to being
a leader is you have to want to be one
um so any of us can volunteer to be a
leader
and that's what you do you commit
yourself to seeing that the people with
whom we work on a daily basis love
coming to work they feel that someone's
got their back they feel supported they
feel that they have top cover they feel
someone cares about them as a human
being listens to them knows their story
allows them to be themselves
we can be that leader
and what you start to see is those teams
becomes
really high performing those teams
become super tight and you start to hear
rumors across the company because
everybody wants into that team because
apparently it's a great team to work
with to work on
um and before you know it one of those
people goes and moves to another team
and they take everything that they
learned because leadership has learned
and they do it for another team and if
we take that infinite mindset
then eventually the tail will wag the
dog and it doesn't matter if it's this
ceo or another ceo because we will
outlast whoever's in charge right now
and that's the goal we're doing this for
the good of the organization we're doing
this for the good of the cause
right and the tail can whack the dog and
rule number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus clips is a line rank
with responsibility leadership and
authority are not the same thing
title affords you authority affords you
rank right um but that doesn't make you
a leader i know many people who sit at
high levels of organizations who are not
leaders
um we do as they tell us because they
have authority over us
but we don't trust them and wouldn't
follow them anywhere
um and we i know many people at low
levels of organizations that have no
formal rank no formal authority but
they've made the choice to look after
the person to the left of them and
and take care of the person to the right
of them uh and we would trust them and
follow them anywhere
and so
rank affords you the opportunity to lead
at scale
it affords you the opportunity to take
care of more people
implement systems and and incentive
structures and all the rest of it and
reward behaviors to to to to to you can
influence culture
with rank but that doesn't make you a
leader
and you still have to study the the
the the tenets of leadership
and and and when they align it's magical
you know when you have rank and you and
you've been studying leadership then you
can then you can actually affect the
culture in a in a more robust way and
and one of the primary responsibilities
of any leader is to make more leaders
and and you can do that at scale if you
have authority
being the person in charge doesn't make
you the leader yeah every single person
has the capacity to be the leader they
wish they had yeah and so i'm a great
believer that leaders are made not born
right it's a skill set yeah you can
learn it you can practice it not
everybody wants to learn it not
everybody's going to be good at it and
it takes a lifetime of work it does and
you'll never be the best right and so
for people who want to be the leader
they wish they had they have to become
students of leadership you have to read
books you have to watch talks you have
to read articles you have to have
conversations about it you and i have
these conversations when we're not on
camera all the time all the time
right we are genuinely interested in the
subject and when we hang out with each
other and that's what we talk about
that's what we talk about we talk about
this stuff all the time yeah right
so you know i talk to small companies
all the time and say we don't have a
budget for uh for our leadership
training i'm like do you have the budget
to buy a book
right order podcasts or videos like club
yeah once once a week get together over
lunch and talk about a chapter of a book
that everybody's reading
or an article that you read or a ted
talk or a podcast that you know give
everybody homework to watch something
for 18 minutes and then talk about it on
friday at lunch congratulations you have
a leadership development program and
don't assign anybody to run it ask the
people who are already reading the books
watching the
the talks and listening to the podcast
ask them to leave it because they have
genuine interest
every single one of us can be the leader
we wish we had so on monday if you want
to be the leader you wish you had then
start really learning become a student
of leadership do do watch one
talk listen to one podcast buy a new
book about the subject
and just do it yourself whether the
company endorses it or not do it biggest
risk you've ever taken um
i completely changed the course of my
life and career when i discovered this
thing called the why i abandoned what i
was doing and said i want to do that and
people thought i was crazy they thought
i went out of business but i was so i
believed in it so much i i threw caution
into the wind
i think why has been the key my whole
life the worldwide so it's it's a little
kid question that we grow out of for
some reason here's what i've learned
about mentorship um mentorship is not
something you ask somebody to do like
will you be my friend it doesn't work
like that um when you find somebody you
get along with you share values you
share beliefs you spend time with them
you get to know them you develop trust
you take
you're vulnerable with them you open up
to them and you discover that you become
friends it's what happens you start off
as simply acquaintances um in in my
experience mentorship is exactly the
same um there were people who were much
more experienced than me who had wisdom
that i didn't have and i when i would
call them they would take my calls and
when when i would ask them questions
they would always take the time to give
me answers
and over the course of time they became
my mentors like they became my friends
and i remember one time i was with one
of my mentors ron bruder an amazing guy
and i was leaving his house and i put my
arm around him i said you know i'm glad
you're my mentor and he looked at me and
he said i'm glad you're mine and it
caught me completely off guard and true
mentorship like true friendship is not a
one-way street it's not about one person
only giving advice to the other both
people are showing up to give and both
people are showing up uh to learn um but
you can't ask someone to be your mentor
especially someone who's a total
stranger knock on their door and say
will you be my mentor if they don't know
you you've never met them it's like
friendship you cultivate a relationship
and if that person is always there for
you and wants to see you thrive and
succeed and believes in you
then perhaps they will become your
mentor like making a friend discovering
your why is just the beginning
in order to enjoy all the benefits of
having a clearly articulated why you'll
need to have the courage and discipline
to use it
like thomas edison said vision with that
execution is hallucination
there is an ideal order for implementing
your why though sometimes reality does
get in the way and it all starts with
you
our natural tendency is to start with
the tangible we define our value by what
we do so it takes practice to start with
why like riding a bicycle at first we're
unsure unsteady we're in our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over even scrape our knees but
we get back on the bike and try again
and eventually it becomes natural
starting with why is no different at
first it feels awkward it may not even
work but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't do it
just like riding a bicycle
in time your why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions and choices
you make it becomes a tool to help you
find a job or seize an opportunity in
which you're more likely to succeed
it removes a lot of the guessing
here's a metaphor to show you what i
mean it's called the celery test
we're constantly asking people for their
advice on what to do or how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need m ms we've done so well with m
m's you've got to use m ms somebody else
says to us rice milk in this economy you
have to use rice milk
someone else says to us kit kats you
have to use kit kats and somebody else
says to you it's all about celery we go
to the supermarket with all this good
advice from all these smart people with
brilliant case studies and we buy
everything we buy kit kats and m ms
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout line
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything
but let's imagine we know our why let's
imagine our why is to always be healthy
and only do things that protect the
health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people this time we only buy celery and
we only buy rice milk they're the only
two that makes sense
we spend less time and less money at the
supermarket and when we're standing
there in line with only celery and only
rice milk now people can see what we
believe
somebody walking past can say hey i can
see that you're healthy so am i you just
attracted an opportunity or a referral
or a friend simply by saying and doing
the things that you believe
and the best part is it's scalable
as soon as i said the why you knew
exactly which products we were going to
buy
this means the more you can articulate
your why the more others will know what
you stand for and will be able to help
you make the right decisions from now on
you will work to ensure everything you
do is a good fit
if you do too many things that aren't a
good fit you'll feel uncomfortable and
people will feel that you're being
inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why
your ability to stand out find support
and work to all your natural strengths
will flourish
with practice you will learn to trust
your why you will eventually start to
see your job and the things you do as
ways to breathe life into your cause
and the better you get at it the more
you will feel that your life and
everything you do has purpose
the best way to implement your why is to
work at it slowly you don't have to do
all the tips we suggest what is
important is that you pick up to three
and commit to practicing and using them
now what do good leaders have in common
um they have the courage to do the right
thing
um they're people of high character and
high integrity um but for me the big one
is courage it's it's very hard to be a
leader it's hard to speak truth to power
very often you might be the one that
gets in trouble or lose your job um it's
hard to do the right thing it's much
easier to do the expedient thing
um and um and it's also a huge
undertaking to be a leader every every
moment of every day it's
kind of like being a parent here's a
thing that's always boggled my mind
right
why is it on balance on balance not
always but on balance why is it that
small companies tend to be more
innovative than big companies right
small companies that are under-resourced
can't necessarily get the best and
brightest
they're going to go to business any day
and yet there's they come with brilliant
ideas and big companies full of
resources full of amazing people
by the little companies that come up
with the good ideas that's usually how
big companies innovate they buy the
smaller ones right
um why is that why is it that the most
resource companies tend not and i think
it's a question of reality and what i
mean by that is small companies their
vision
is is more distant than their grasp
right they have delusions of grandeur
we're going to change the world change
industries reinvent this reinvent that
we have no money and no people but so
what my point is is the grasp is shorter
than the vision
and i think what happens is as companies
get bigger and bigger and bigger with
more and more resources what they start
to do is one of two things
either
their their visions become well within
their grasp and they don't readjust the
vision or they actually bring the vision
back to put within their grasps
right
make things very achievable difficult
but achievable
for vision to truly be vision it should
feel unachievable when a small business
gets together and says here's our vision
everybody goes like this
how are we going to do that
in big businesses we see here's a vision
where he goes all right
yeah no got it we'll do a back plan
and i i firmly believe that innovation
is born out of the struggle innovation
is born out of the the resourcefulness
that you're forced to figure out because
literally the vision is way beyond your
grasp regardless of how many resources
you have it should always feel
overwhelming and impossible so how do
you define success
i think success is is
is seeing those around you work to their
natural best and creating momentum
for a vision towards a vision that will
last
beyond yourself
so a guy is driving a bus
for 20 years he's got to retire he's on
madison avenue in new york packed every
day as people getting on that bus and
getting off
he has two kids
wife lives in queens
he might call himself successful another
guy might be vice president of that
company
who would call himself
unsuccessful so is success what you make
of it
so it's
so this success is defined it's success
is a feeling it's not a it's not a
series of check marks and goals i think
people define success as as finish lines
you know they well i ran a marathon i'm
successful the question is a why did you
run the marathon and what happens after
you've completed the marathon do you
just keep running marathons what happens
if you break your leg and you can no
longer run marathons you know we set a
lot of people set um financial goals i'm
successful when i make my first million
ah okay now i have to make my second
million it's success is a feeling and
and it's the feeling of contribution so
your bus driver in queens if he has
decided that his job as a bus driver is
to ensure that everyone who gets on his
bus
feels better about themselves because
they got on his bus and not another bus
and so he greets them with a smile he
says good morning he says goodbye
that people will remember that that
that uh that ride that they took with
him versus the this vice president of
the company who's made it about himself
and his financial goals he's the one
who's unhappy as opposed to seeing those
around him succeed and those around him
go home with a love of their their day
you know because they come to work in
his company every day so i i still
believe success and and good leadership
are about service to others what you'll
find is that that um
the better you are at communicating your
why
um people will want to work for you uh
regardless of the opportunity that you
afford them like they want to be a part
of it yeah um we do a little thing which
we've been doing for years and years and
years called a give and take whenever
there's any kind of relationship whether
it's a
an outside partnership or even uh
somebody who joins our team we do
something called a give and take where
we want somebody to be selfish and
selfless within the relationship
so not give and get but given take so
we'll ask them what is it that you have
to give to us that you have that you
think that we need right and they'll
tell us and then we'll say great what is
it that you selfishly want from us and
we want them to tell us what they can
get from us and that's what we're doing
and when those when those things match
you have a balanced relationship because
so for example i've had it with people
you know they'll tell me what they what
they have to offer and that's awesome
because that's what i want and then
they'll say what they have what they
want to take and they go oh i want to
work with the smart people i'm like
plenty of smart people what is it you
want to take from me they're like oh i
want to help build something
wonderful do that anywhere what do you
want to take selfishly from me that you
can get nowhere else and if they can't
answer the question the game
of business
is
an infinite game
right it obeys all the rules um there
are known and unknown players you don't
know all the competitors necessarily in
one industry to another
the rules are changeable we haven't all
agreed what the rules are
and there is no winning the game of
business right the game just perpetuates
in fact the game of business has existed
longer than every single company on the
planet today and it will outlast every
single commodore company on the planet
today if you look at the dow index of 30
something odd companies that make up the
dow index something like 70 or 80
of those companies are 35 years or
younger
right
so
it gets me thinking if you listen
to the language that companies use
they don't know what game they're in
they talk about being number one
talk about beating their competition
based on what agreed upon
criteria based on what agreed upon time
frame is it market share is it profits
is it revenues
square footage number of employees over
what one month five months six months a
year five years ten years the life of
the company i haven't agreed to those
rules
and so companies can arbitrarily declare
themselves number one in anything they
want if they set the standards and the
time frames and the only reason we do
these things on annualized basis we tend
to we tend to compare ourselves to other
organizations annually
is only because we pay taxes annually if
we pay taxes every 18 months that would
be sort of the standard but again we
still haven't agreed
what the metrics are to be number one
that means
the companies that are playing the
infinite game
are playing against most of the others
who are playing the finite game means
those finite companies find themselves
in quagmire
almost every single bankruptcy not
almost every every single bankruptcy is
a company that's run out of the will or
the resources to play they drop out of
the game the game will persist another
company will fill their space it's not
like it's not like the business stops or
the industry ends
and
the companies that are playing the
infinite game will frustrate those
finite players which i absolutely adore
so i spoke at an education summit for
microsoft
i also spoke at an education summit for
apple
now i would say about 70 to 80 percent
of the executives at microsoft spent
about 70 to 80 percent of their
power points
talking about how to beat apple
at the apple summit 100 of the
executives spent a hundred percent of
their presentations talking about how to
help teachers teach and how to help
students learn
one was obsessed with their journey with
their vision with their cause the other
one was obsessed with their competition
guess who's stuck in quagmire guess
who's frustrated by their competition so
i'll tell you another story
it's a personal story it's not one that
i share very often
and it profoundly changed
the course of my life
in august of 2011
i had the opportunity to visit
afghanistan with the united states air
force
i had done some work with the mobility
forces these the people that fly the
tankers and the cargo planes and air
force one
all the big planes
and the general said to me simon you've
gotten to know us quite well
it would mean a lot to me
if you would go
to either iraq or afghanistan
to see our men and women perform their
mission
would you be willing to go
so i said yes
they picked afghanistan
now i didn't tell my parents where i was
going because i didn't want them to
worry
i told them i was going away with the
air force true
i told them i was going to be out of
touch for a while because i was going to
be on a lot of planes
true
i told them i was going to germany
true
i just didn't tell them from germany i
was going to afghanistan
and i had no responsibility i was simply
going as an observer
i had two officers who were assigned to
be my escorts and we met basically for
the first time
uh at penn station in philadelphia where
we drove to dover air force base where
we would leave for germany we took a big
c5 cargo plane
in germany we changed planes and we got
on a kc-135 tanker
built in 1956.
i was on a plane built in 1956.
um
where we flew to bagram
we landed in the middle of the night
we touched down
and the big door in the side of the
plane had opened but we hadn't gotten
off the plane yet we'd been on the we'd
been on the ground for maybe 10 minutes
and the base came under rocket attack
three rockets hit a hundred yards off
our nose this is how my trip began
now if you've ever been in a war zone
for those of you in the room who've ever
been in a war zone you have you know
this you have all the feelings you're
supposed to have you just don't have
them at the right times
weirdly i was incredibly relaxed and
maybe that's because the people i was
with were incredibly relaxed and i felt
safe
we revenge the panic came later
eventually given the all clear and we
went to our housing
now the purpose of being in afghanistan
we were going to be in the country for
up to 30 hours and the goal was to
witness an airdrop mission
they're not regularly scheduled so we
had to find out if there was one as soon
as we got there and it turns out there
was one first thing in the morning
so we got about two and a half hours
three hours of sleep
and we went and got on this air drop
mission which was incredible we sat in
the back of a c-17 we flew about an hour
and a half two hours out to the middle
of nowhere afghanistan the plane dropped
down to about 2000 feet the back door
opened and we sat there and watched as
cargo flew out the back so we could
resupply an army forward operating base
it was an amazing amazing experience
we then flew back to bagram and the goal
was to come back home
there's no regularly scheduled flight so
we have to sort of find out what flights
we can get on and it's always up to the
discretion of the pilots we found a
flight that was leaving
um shortly after we got back and so we
uh asked the pilots and they said
absolutely we can join their flight and
we waited and waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited and
eventually we got on the plane we were
all strapped in literally five minutes
from leaving and the pilot walked up to
us and said i'm sorry we need to bump
you guys we need to make more room for
stretchers it was carrying wounded
warriors out of out of theater and they
needed our space if there's ever a good
reason to get bumped off a plane this
was it so we got off the plane and we
went to look for another flight
and that's when we found out
there were no other flights until
tuesday and this was only saturday
i was going to get stuck in afghanistan
for at least four days maybe longer
because we don't know what we're going
to get on on tuesday and i have no way
of telling my parents
they're not going to hear from me on the
date that i told them that i would get
home
immediately every fiber of my being sank
and i remember becoming completely
panicked
and completely preoccupied with one
thing
my happiness my safety and my comfort
and i didn't care who had to go out of
their way to get me what i wanted
i remember there was a public affairs
officer who said i can get you to
kyrgyzstan but you don't have the right
visa and i looked at him and i said you
get me on that plane i don't talk to
people like that and i could see myself
becoming this person that i hated
some of us in the room have worked for
somebody in our careers who
wants the next promotion and they don't
care that they have to tie our turn our
lives upside down so they can get what
they want i was becoming that person
we went back to our housing
and i lay down on the bed and closed my
eyes
my mind was racing i was convinced that
there would be another rocket attack on
the base i was convinced that i was
going to get hit i was convinced that my
parents were going to find out that i
was in afghanistan when an armed an air
force officer knocks on the door i was
convinced paranoia fear everything that
you can imagine swept over me
one of the officers that i was traveling
with said i'm gonna see if i can get us
on another flight and he left the room
the other officer thinking i was asleep
just because my eyes were closed said
well i'm going to go to the gym then and
he walked out and turned off the lights
for me
i couldn't sleep my mind was racing all
i wanted to do was get out of there i
regretted saying yes i regretted being
there i didn't want to be there
i'm in the purpose business i write and
talk about this sense of why and sense
of purpose in our lives
so i started to remind myself simon you
need a purpose you don't have a purpose
you need a purpose so i started
inventing one
you're here to tell their story
it worked for like a few minutes and
then it would slide back into my fear
and panic again
and i realized what was happening to me
is i was living the equivalent of an
unfulfilled life compressed into 24
hours
i had an amazing day i got to see
something that most people will never
get to see in their entire lives except
i didn't want to wake up and do it again
the next day
and i think many of us do the same thing
we can we confuse moments of happiness
with joy and fulfillment
we confuse winning a piece of business
getting a promotion getting an award
getting recognition doing well on a test
with actual deep fulfillment
those experiences are wonderful but
happiness is fleeting there's not a
single person in this room absolutely
zero who's walking around with an
amazing sense of accomplishment for that
test that you aced a year ago
that feeling
is gone
fulfillment is something entirely
different
it's something you carry with you on a
daily basis whether you're enjoying the
day or not it's like loving your family
you may not like your family every day
but you love your family every day
one is fleeting the other
is lasting
and this is what was happening to me i'd
realized that i had this amazing day and
i was confusing
happiness and fulfillment
and so i gave up i lay in that bed
paranoid scared and depressed and i
literally
gave up
i decided that if i was going to get
stuck here
i might as well make myself useful
and so i decided i was going to
volunteer i would speak anywhere they
wanted me to speak
i would carry boxes and sweep floors all
i wanted to do was serve some of those
amazing people that i'd met on this trip
i wanted to serve those who served
others
and instantly this incredible calm came
over me
i was even
excited
this is what fulfillment means
it's not the fleeting joys that we may
experience it's not the accomplishments
that we achieve
it's the opportunity to serve those who
serve others
and upon making this realization i had
nothing but joy and calm and excitement
and peace
it was like a movie the timing was
uncanny upon making this amazing
realization the door flung open
and it was major throk morton he said i
got us on a flight there's been a flight
that's been redirected but we have to go
now we have to go now if we don't leave
now they're going to leave without us
where's matt i said he's at the gym
so we ran to the gym we got him off the
treadmill we ran back no time to shower
he put his uniform back on we grabbed
all our stuff and we ran out to the
flight line
when we got out to the flight line we
could see the plane we were going to go
we were going to take home
see big c17 it was sitting right out
there on the tarmac and as soon as we
got there a security cordon came down
and they wouldn't let us out to the
plane
because somewhere else on base
they were having a fallen soldier
ceremony
and out of respect when they have the
fallen soldiers ceremony everything
stops
and so so we we sat on the curb and
waited
and i told the guys what i had gone
through
in the bed just moments ago
and i cried like a baby
and this is one of the things a lot of
people don't realize about the military
crying is just fine
those guys kept me safe not just
physically they made me feel safe
and i felt totally comfortable telling
them what i was going through and how i
felt eventually the security cordon came
up and they let us out to the plane we
would be the only three passengers
aboard this plane other than the crew
what i didn't tell you
is the reason the flight was redirected
is because we would be carrying home the
fallen soldier for whom they just had
the ceremony
the army
brought the flag draped casket on board
all the air force crew stood in the line
at perfect attention i'm a civilian i
put my hand on my heart i felt kind of
stupid so i stood at attention with the
air force
crew as the army laid the casket in the
middle of the aircraft they holded a
very slow eight-count salute
they marched off the plane
and we watched them hugging and crying
as they walked away
the crew got to work strapping this
precious cargo down
we then had a nine and a half hour
overnight flight back to germany where i
slept right next to this casket
on every other plane i went on we talked
we joked barely a word was spoken in
nearly 10 hours
on every other flight i visited the
cockpit and hung out with the crew i
didn't visit the cockpit once
and i'll tell you it was one of the
greatest honors of my life
having just gone through this incredibly
strange experience on the ground
i had the honor of bringing home
somebody who understands service much
deeper than i will ever understand it
serve those who serve others
and you will live a life of joy
and fulfillment a few months ago i
stayed at the
four seasons in las vegas
it is a wonderful hotel
and the reason it's a wonderful hotel is
not because of the fancy beds any hotel
can go and buy a fancy bed the reason
it's a wonderful hotel is because of the
people who work there if you walk past
somebody at the four seasons and this
and they say hello to you you get the
feeling that they actually wanted to say
hello to you it's not that somebody told
them that you have to say hello to all
the customers say hello to all the
guests right you actually feel that they
care
now in their lobby they have
a coffee stand and i one afternoon i
went to buy a cup of coffee and there
was a barista by the name of noah who
was serving me noah was fantastic he was
friendly and fun
and he was engaging with me and i had so
much fun buying a cup of coffee i
actually think i gave 100 tip right he
was wonderful so as is my nature i asked
noah
do you like your job and without
skipping a beat noah says
i love my job
and so i followed up i said what is it
that the four seasons is doing
that would make you say to me
i love my job and without skipping a
beat
noah said throughout the day managers
will walk past me and ask me how i'm
doing if there's anything that i need to
do my job better he said not just my
manager
any manager
and then he said something magical
he says
i also work at caesar's palace
and caesar's at caesar's palace the
managers are trying to make sure we're
doing everything right they catch us
when we do things wrong
he says when i go to work there i like
to keep my head under the radar and just
get through the day so i can get my
paycheck
he says here at the four seasons i feel
i can be myself
same person
entirely a different experience from the
from the customer who will engage with
noah so we in leadership are always
criticizing the people we're always
saying we've got to get the right people
on the bus i've got to fill my wrong my
team i got to get the right people but
the reality is it's not the people it's
the leadership
if we create the right environment we
will get people like noah at the four
seasons if we create the wrong
environment we will get people like noah
at caesar's palace
it's not the people and yet we're so
quick to hire and fire
you can't hire and fire your children
if there's if your kids are struggling
we don't say you got to see at school
you're up for adoption
so why is it that when somebody has
performance problems at work
why is it that our instinct is to say
you're out
we do not practice
empathy what does empathy look like
here's the lack of empathy this is
normal in our business world you walk
into someone's office someone walks into
our office and says your numbers have
been down for the third quarter in a row
you have to pick up your numbers
otherwise i can't guarantee what the
future will look like how inspired you
think that person is to come to work the
next day
here's what empathy looks like
you walk into someone's office someone
walks into your office and says your
numbers are down for the third quarter
in a row
are you okay
i'm worried about you
what's going on
we all have performance issues maybe
someone's kid is sick maybe they're
having problems in their marriage maybe
one of their parents is dying we don't
know what's going on in their lives and
of course it will affect performance at
work empathy is being concerned about
the human being not just their output
and we have to practice empathy i was
living in london and attending law
school i was becoming disillusioned with
the law i happened to be dating a girl
who was in advertising she said you
might like advertising and boom i have a
career in marketing like i fell into it
so many of us fall into our careers and
full entire jobs and even if we do
pursue something we want to do sometimes
it takes diversions right this is this
is what i mean by living our lives by
accident which is we largely leave the
direction of our careers and sometimes
even our own happiness to others our
bosses
you know all of that thing
so what it means to live your life on
purpose means you understand the
direction you're heading but you remain
agnostic as to the root most people try
very very hard to plan the route in
other words what's your plan people say
well first i'm going to work here for
three years then i'm gonna quit and i'm
gonna do this and then for four years
and i got the root plan and the question
is where are you going right and that to
me is what it means to have purpose it
means to have destination
right it's like waking up in the morning
and saying i'm going on holiday and
somebody says where are you going he
said i'm going on vacation i told you
you're like where are you going vacation
right um and so how are you going to get
there you're like well i'm taking route
95. so you've got the route planned but
you have no destination and you see this
in companies all the time you know why
does your company exist growth
great why are you growing why do you
need to grow what does growth mean
because we're a company we have to grow
and so they figure out all of these
paths for growth but they don't know
where they're going i would rather
someone wake up in the morning and say
california i'm trying to get to
california and i don't care what route i
take i'm going to start down route 95
and if i find a better route i'm going
to take it if there's traffic on route
95 i'm going to take a side road so this
is what happened in my career people
kept telling me that i was unfocused
because i kept taking side roads i
wasn't unfocused i was going around
obstacles
so that's what it means to live a life
of purpose it means i live every single
day of my life trying to get to an end
point in my case to create a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired to go
to work
feel safe when they're there and return
home at the end of the day fulfilled by
the work that they do that is the
destination i'm trying to
reach i don't know how i'm going to get
there but i'm going to try every path i
can to get there highly highly focused
that's what it means to live a life on
purpose we're often given this advice
like do what you love yeah like what am
i supposed to do with it yes like find
your passion like thank you like great
like i don't know what to do tomorrow
for me
passion is the result of something right
so if you work hard for something you
don't believe in that's called stress
and if you work for so hard for
something you do believe in that's
called passion so it's finding the
belief it's finding the cause it's
finding the purpose and the passion then
shows up courageous leaders are the ones
who are willing to sacrifice the short
term in order to advance the long term
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to say no to the money because
it's coming from a dirty source
and rather say yes even though they know
they'll have to tighten the belt in the
short term because it's the right thing
to do
having a just cause if we don't actually
follow the just cause if we don't
actually make decisions through the lens
of the just cause it's just marketing
it's just marketing i'll give you my
favorite example right the ioc the
international olympic committee they
have a mission statement what they
believe is their just cause which is to
uh
advance the world make the world a
better place through sport
but for the fact that they're all
corrupt
it's a great idea
my point is is you actually have to have
leadership that
desperately profoundly believes in the
cause and will make decisions to advance
that cause they would sooner sacrifice
their own personal interests to take
care of their people they would never
sacrifice their people to protect their
own interests
it's called leadership
it's called leadership
we confuse rank and leadership
rank has nothing to do with leadership
i know many people who sit at the
highest levels of organizations who are
not leaders they have authority
and we do as they tell us because they
have authority over us but we would not
follow them
and yet i know many people who sit at
lower ranks who have no authority and
yet they have made a choice the choice
to look after the person to the left of
them and the choice to look after the
person to the right of them and we would
trust them and follow them anywhere
leadership is the acceptance of the
awesome responsibility
to create an environment in which people
can work at their natural best i went to
see a play with a friend of mine who is
an actor
and the play was awful
i mean
a train wreck
the script was awful the directing was
awful i mean it was an absolute train
wreck the question you asked was about
collaboration right should any of those
actors have taken the part now
of course
if you're going to take apart because
you need an extra cash a little extra
cash or you want to get a little extra
practice then you have to do so i think
knowing i'm doing this for the money or
i'm doing this just to keep keep my
my skills sharp but i'm under no
illusion
that this is something that i connect
with but i'm going to do the best that i
can and then don't
lie to yourself you know the other
problem is don't do that too often
because that'll just destroy any passion
that you have for your medium right and
i think
and we've talked about this which is
which is
any artist any person but especially
artists have to know their why you have
to know why you're showing up in the
first place
and you have to be able to talk about it
because if you talk about it things
happen people go
i like you right now you may not get the
part
but you're more likely to find people
who want to work with you even if you're
not the most talented one who auditioned
this is my career by the way
right when i learn to talk about what i
believed
i didn't talk about the things i've done
i didn't talk about the parts i've had
or the shows i've been in or who trained
me
or the schools i went to resume resume
resume
i started i learned to talk about what i
believed and some people thought it was
cheesy
they didn't call me back
good
and some people went
that's great
and i was not the most talented not the
most experienced
not the best at my field but because
they stood for or believed in what i
stood for
they wanted to work with me
they would rather work with someone who
understood them who got them
more than somebody who would just take
orders and do exactly what they wanted
regardless of facility there's a paradox
being a human being um unfortunately at
all times every moment of every day we
are both individuals and members of
groups right we are both responsible for
ourselves and our own happiness and our
own joy but at the same time we're
members of families we're members of
churches we're members of teams we're
members of companies like we're members
of multiple groups every single day at
every moment and this produces some
complications we have to make decisions
so do we put ourselves first or do we
put the group first and there's a debate
some people say oh you have to take care
of yourself before you can take care of
the group and some say no no you take
care of the group and that's what helps
they will take care of you and the
answer is yes it's not one or the other
it's actually both simultaneously um it
is a challenge but at the end of the day
there's no getting around it as social
animals our success our happiness our
joy our ability to get anything done
requires help
and
those who embrace the fact that they
cannot do everything alone that they
need the support and love and it doesn't
mean somebody who's physically helping
you live something sometimes it might be
someone who just believes in you
these things are essential and there's
just no getting around it the next part
is a worthy rival
now i said before that the only true
competitor in an uh an infinite game is
yourself this is true what your
competition does is it helps reveal to
you your weaknesses
admire
the others in your organization not to
beat them there's no such thing not to
be number one there's no such thing but
if somebody else is better than you at
something that means you have to go work
harder yourself it's like running in a
race if you're driven to be number one
if you're driven to make the most money
if you're driven to show up in some
arbitrary ranking that you don't even
have a say in
that's like
tripping the the next runner you will
win the race
but you're still a slow runner
rather
fall behind this year
and then you work and work and work
because ultimately the goal is not to be
number one this year the goal is to
create an organization that will outlast
every single one of you
this is about building strong
foundations
this is about looking long-term in the
short term money is simply fuel to to to
uh to make the car go
we don't own cars to buy more fuel
we own cars to go somewhere
it's the same thing in an organization
your organization exists to advance
something
the money is simply there to make a go
and i fear
that what has happened in the university
system is similar to what i'm seeing
in
business it's similar to what i'm seeing
in politics it's similar to what i'm
seeing in hospitals
which is an over uh the sense of
excessive pressure to bring money in
at the expense of something else
there's an excessive amount of
short-termism
and massive amounts of rationalizing
this is just the game
we just have to do it if we don't
somebody else will
the obsession with getting grants
meaning you're hiring people who are
more likely to help you get a grant
even though they're teaching things that
we don't necessarily even need or want
that's called short-termism these people
always complain that why can't i ever
get that and these people complain i can
never get a job
you're gonna be stressed no matter what
focus on the thing that you're getting
because that's the choice you made right
i'd rather much rather you focus the
thing you you you're you're pursuing
rather the thing you're missing
and so this idea of affirmative thinking
positive thinking is essential for all
people but i think it's especially
essential for artists and there's a very
very simple
biological reason for it
which is the human brain cannot
comprehend the negative
it is incapable
yes it's true
i'll give you an example
[Music]
okay no no i'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
i'll prove it
i'll prove it okay the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something
right and so what happens is we very
often reinforce things
when we put things in the negative
right i can't get apart
i can't get apart
i can't get apart right or
um
um
i can't do this
versus i'm going to keep doing this
i'm going to keep doing this
i'm going to keep doing this
right
um
and and it's it's such a huge thing to
convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well we're supposed to say instead of
saying to children
don't eat on the couch we're supposed to
say eat at the table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not want them what we don't want
to do pilots know this
right it is well known in the pilot
community that when you tell a pilot
don't hit the obstacle they'll hit the
obstacle
because what they're doing is focusing
on the obstacle i went to this event and
just by sheer coincidence at the dinner
i'm sitting next to dawn and sam
goldwurm who run this company called
1229 and that's exactly what they do
dawn is a master nose
who used to work for cody the perfume
company so you produce all the famous
perfumes that we all know
and they want us to start their own
company where they design custom sense
for brands
but the way to think about this is
beyond sort of verbena and patchouli
the way dawn explained it to me is
there are seven notes on the musical
scale
and you can play chopsticks or you can
play a beethoven symphony it's the same
seven notes it's what you do with it and
she does the same thing with smell which
is you can have simple smells or you can
have highly complex ornate orchestras uh
symphonies rather and so they sat down
with me and took me through a fantastic
process and they produced the smell of
optimism
and it's the most beautiful thing and
the idea was born out of the fact that
i'm sitting next to this event and i
turned them and said have you ever sent
it a book has that ever been done before
and they said no it's never been done i
said well we should really do that
and so of course my publisher was not
excited to hear about that but but uh
it's the first time that i know that a
book has ever been centered in this way
so it is a scented book
the smell of optimism
is what you start with and it sets you
on your journey to enjoy the rest of the
book why does your organization
exist
we don't need you clearly there's plenty
of competition clearly people have
plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you
but i know that the culture of one
organization is different than the
culture of another organization there
are cultural norms that wrap around the
sense of purpose cause or belief
great organizations understand their
just cause
cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas turning down a better job that
offers me more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite
examples of a just cause
is
the declaration of independence
our founding fathers
declared literally wrote down they
declared why
we needed our own country
all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
they were never against britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided all men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war
george washington understood how
limiting that was and he realized that
they had to have a broader definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend mass to send the right
message
some time later
we abolished slavery
and the 14th amendment
some time later we had women's suffrage
sometime later we had
civil rights act sometime later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving
to provide this thing called all men are
equal people are equal and though we'll
never actually get there we will die
trying and the obstacles may always be
different
and what a just cause is
it is a vision of the future that does
not yet exist and you will commit all of
your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there
believe in your vision of the future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else because they want to
be
around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is
superficial things it's like dating
right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they're
talking about their character
and those are the people we want to
spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for what their
purpose what their cause what their
beliefs are what their values are
the only thing we have to judge them on
is how much money they make and how good
looking they are i'm a huge modern dance
lover like that's the thing i love
and
i don't go to the joyce anymore
because everything that they have on
their stage is good
it's good
everything is safe to me
they put things on their stage that's
good they sell tickets
nothing's bad
and nothing's great
it's all good i don't go anymore i go to
bam a lot
i have seen things that have profoundly
changed my view of the world and i have
walked out of more things at bam
literally i'm like i'm done
and my friend's like you can't i'm like
we can
you know
i have walked outs out of so many things
at bam
and yet i continue to go and continue to
go and i continue to go because i know
what they stand for
that's my preference
i'm not saying it's right or wrong i'm
saying that's my preference
that i would rather take the risk of
walking out
knowing that i might get moved in a way
that i've never experienced before more
than just go and have a nice night out
and see something that i know is good
right and i think that goes for our
careers
as well
you know which is
if you choose to be the kind of artist
that stands for something that you want
to be yourself and bring yourself into
everything that you do
you will get fewer parts
you will
the parts you get
will move you in a way that most artists
will not get moved
or
you can bend and manipulate yourself a
little bit and sort of be a little bit
more of what they want
and play their role and even though you
don't really buy into it it's a part and
i want to be an actor i want to be a
performer i'm going to i'm going to do
what they want you will absolutely get
more parts
without a doubt you will you will can
arguably have a better career
but will you be profoundly moved as an
artist the odds are lower it's not i
can't say never it's just the odds are
lower it's not better or worse it is
simply the decision
on how you choose to manage or lead your
own career
both are acceptable
right one means you get to use your
facility a lot
one means you get to work a lot one
means you might be able to do only your
art and actually make a living
one means that you're going to be
meeting a lot of people and the odds are
that you will connect with somebody at
some point
or
you choose this route
which is much more difficult
and is fraught with much more risk
and much more struggle
but you become known for the thing that
you are the word entrepreneur is bandied
about too loosely
that not everyone who owns a small
business is an entrepreneur there are
small business owners and they're
entrepreneurs what's an entrepreneur and
you can find entrepreneurs in big
companies
it doesn't mean that they're small
business owners right
i think entrepreneurs are problem
solvers
i think rather than risk takers yeah i
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers i think who are
entrepreneurs there's a risk taker of
your small business owner
right
you went out to start the business but
they're not the same i don't think
and entrepreneurs are those ones who
they're constantly looking to solve
problems and that's where i think they
perceive opportunity or the mischief
that you describe i don't think it's i
don't think inherently it's a sense of
mischief they're not trying to stir the
pot for the sake of stirring the pot i
think that they see something and
they're like we can make that better or
we can fill that hole
and that's very much the way the famous
entrepreneurs the elon musks and the
richard bransons operate they see gaps
they see things that don't work as their
jobs as did jobs they see things that
could be better are they
i mean elon musk was just interviewed by
chris anderson at ted last week
and
uh chris anderson sort of near the end
of the interview it's online go watch it
it's really
great
um
uh
chris anderson asks elon musk something
to the effect of
why why are you doing all these things
like why don't you just stick with tesla
and be done with it like why do all the
other stuff and you look at and musk you
can see this look on his face and he
takes a long time to answer he actually
doesn't understand the question
he cannot understand
why you wouldn't do that
and he sort of gets emphatic which elon
musk is pretty amazing because he
doesn't get emphatic
but that's basically what it is he gets
emphatic and says because i want to live
in a world that's better than this or
words to that effect you know where i am
not where the world that we're living
right now makes us unhappy why don't we
want to live in a world that makes us
happy
you know he gets sort of
he can't understand and again it's
vision first
and that's why he doesn't understand why
you wouldn't try and solve problems a
friend of mine and i
we went for a run in central park
the road runners organization uh on the
weekends they host races
and it's very common at the end of the
race they'll have a sponsor who will
give away something apples or bagels or
something and on this particular day
when we got to the end of the run there
were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up and on one side was
a group of volunteers on the table were
boxes of bagels and on the other side
was a long line of runners waiting to
get their free bagel
so i said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel and he looked at me and said
ah the line's too long
and i said
free bagel
and he said i don't want to wait
in line
and i was like
free bagel
and he says nah let's it's too long
and that's when i realized that there's
two ways to see the world
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want
i could only see the bagels
he could only see the line
and so
i walked up to the line
i
leaned in between two people
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels
and no one got mad at me
because the rule is you can go after
whatever you want you just cannot deny
anyone else
to go after whatever they want now i had
to sacrifice choice i didn't get to
choose which bagel i got i got whatever
i pulled out but i didn't have to wait
in line
so the point is is you don't have to
wait in line you don't have to do it the
way everybody else has done it
you can do it your way
you can break the rules you just can't
get in the way of somebody else getting
what they want performing under pressure
whether it's me or anybody else is the
same you know i have the same pressures
as anyone else there's time there's
performance there's financial i mean
there are you know there's deadlines my
pressures are not unique
the situations may be different or you
know but but everybody has the same
kinds of pressures
um but what i found
or what i find fascinating is the
interpretation of the stimuli if let me
let me explain
so i was watching the olympics this last
summer olympics and i was amazed at how
bad the questions were that the
reporters would ask all the athletes and
almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to
compete or after they competed
were you nervous
right
and to a t
all the athletes went
no
right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean what happens when
you're nervous right your heart rate
starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that as i'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say is nervous as excited they
all said the same thing no i'm not
nervous i'm excited
and so i've actually practiced it just
to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement yeah you
know and so where when you i used to
speak in front of a large audience and
somebody would say how do you feel i
should say a little nervous
now when somebody says how do you feel
i'm like really excited actually and it
it came from just sort of telling myself
no no no this is excitement
and it becomes a little bit automatic
later on
but it's kind of a remarkable thing to
deal with pressure by interpreting what
your body is experiencing as excitement
rather than nerves
and it's really kind of effective it
makes you want to rush forward rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience i talk to so many smart
fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're in their entry-level
jobs and i'll ask them how's it going
and they'll say
i think i'm gonna quit
and i'm like why
they say to me
i'm not making an impact
i'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired i mean it was mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you
find joy from
is not something you discover it's not
like i found love
here it is i found a job i love that's
not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what i'm
talking about take a helicopter climb i
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dump and on to the next
ghost and on to the next in the
18th century
there was something that
spread across europe and eventually made
its way to america called puerto fever
also known as the black death of child
bed
basically what was happening
is women were giving birth
and they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth
was the ravage of europe and it got
worse and worse and worse over the
course of over a century
in some hospitals
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth who would die as a result
of giving birth
but this was the renaissance
this was the time of empirical data and
science and we had thrown away things
like tradition and mysticism these were
men of science these were doctors
and these doctors and men of science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work studying and they would
study the corpses
of the
of the women who had died and in the
morning they would conduct autopsies and
then in the afternoon they would go and
deliver babies and finish their rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice oliver wendell
holmes realized
that all of these doctors were
conducting autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands
before they delivered babies in the
afternoon
and he pointed it out and said guys
you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy
for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands
it would go away
and that's exactly what happened when
they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands the
black death of childbed
disappeared
my point is the lesson here is
sometimes you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of science and
empirical uh studiers and
these men of
finance
who are smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions you can take all the
credit in the world for the things that
you do right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must be a balanced equation you
don't get it one way and not the other
you get to take credit
when you also take accountability i
spoke at an education summit for
microsoft i also spoke at an education
summit for
apple
at the education for my at the education
summit for microsoft i would say that 70
of the executives spent about 70 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat apple
at the apple education summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite
and the other one is playing infinite
gets which one gets frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular i absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and fanta it didn't work on
itunes which is a different problem so i
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant
so i'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior apple executive sort
of employee number 12 kind of guy and
you know i like to stir pots so i turned
him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better
than your ipod touch
and he turned to me and he said
i have no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse
the goal isn't to be the best every day
the goal isn't to out to outdo your
competition every day that's a finite
construction if i had said to microsoft
i've got the new ipod touch and it's so
much better than your zoom they would
have said can we see it what does it do
react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play
to be better than themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday
how can we create a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we also have to
play the infinite game it's not about
being ranked number one it's not about
having more followers on twitter than
your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced
before
you are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes
not from comparison
but from advancement nelson mandela is a
particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but nelson mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings
and he remembers two things when his
father would meet with other elders
one
they would always sit in a circle
and two
his father
was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen i would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak i see it in board rooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what i
think but i'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard
it gives everyone else the ability to
feel that they have contributed
and two you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand
from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying
and at the end you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not
practice being the last to speak
that's what nelson mandela did every
decision we make in our lives as
individuals or as organizations
is a piece of communication it's our way
of saying something about who we are and
what we believe
this is why authenticity matters
this is why you have to say and do the
things you actually believe because the
things you say and do are symbols
of who you are and we look for those
symbols so we can find people who
believe what we believe our very
survival depends on it so if you're
putting out false symbols you will
attract people to those symbols but you
won't be able to form trust with them
this is what tiger woods did to us
he lied
he lied he told us what he thought we
wanted to hear
and it was great and we were drawn to it
and all of us who kind of liked that
idea of the sort of the good guy we're
drawn to it until we found out it was a
lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great
athletes of our day
but he didn't he chose to lie good luck
forming trust again tiger we don't
believe you
we don't trust you
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe what you believe if you go
to one of your friends and you say to
one of your friends
how would you like me to dress
so that you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak
so that you'll like me more
right your friends are gonna look and be
like
what are you talking about
come on come on come on what should i
wear so that you'll find me more
appealing and how would you like me to
speak to you so that you'll like me more
and your friends are going to tell you
just be yourself
that's why i like you i don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
industry what do we do we do market
research and we go out and we ask the
customers what kind of things the way we
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things so you'll like us
more it's just as ridiculous
it's just as ridiculous organizations
should say and do the things they
actually believe and they will attract
people who believe what they believe or
they can choose to lie and at the
slightest hint that they might be lying
cynicism sets in and people start saying
i'm not sure i can trust these guys
because there's not a lot of consistency
in all the things they say and do which
means they can't have a very strong
belief set or they're lying to me
and we call them inauthentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me all these positioning
studies we do are inherent we're going
to do a study to find out from people so
we can be more authentic that's
hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats
are ways that people can find you what
you have the ability to do
as designers is create those symbols
and allow people to use those things to
say something about who they are work
for companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part
is to put what they believe into
pictures and words and symbols and
graphics so that other people can use
those things to say something about who
they are
people put harley davidson logos on
their body to say something about who
they are corporate logo
ain't no proctor and gambles tattooed on
anybody's arm
because harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on there not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves
you ever see anybody with a with a mac
laptop put a sticker over that beautiful
shining apple ain't never gonna happen
then how will you know who i am
do you ever see anybody with a pc break
out the windex to clean out their
computer
mac people
have you ever seen a dirty mac
doesn't exist
does not exist why because it's who i am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe
and they're disciplined in how they do
it they're consistent in what they do
and everything they say and everything
they do serves as a symbol of the set of
values and beliefs we use those symbols
to say something about who we are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about who
we are
and when we can find the people who
believe what we believe we're weirdly
drawn to them
because our very survival
depends on it
we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can
discipline with discipline say and do
and do the things you actually believe
strange things start to happen what are
your thoughts and what's your approach
on
finding and building upon passions
passion is not an actionable word
it's correct you know that those who do
the things that they're passionate about
do better but it's not helpful advice
um and so the question is where does
passion come from
passion is a result passion is an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that
you love passion is the feeling you have
that
you would probably do this for free you
know and you can't believe somebody pays
you to do it you know
and i think we mistake that passion is
something we do in our private lives but
it shouldn't be done you know in our
careers for example and i'm a firm
believer that you are who you are and
anybody who says i'm different at home
than i am at work and one of those two
places you're lying and the goal is to
make everything you do in home and at
work something that you have excitement
to do so how do you find the things that
you're excited to do well it's actually
easier than you think
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free you know how can you recreate
that feeling and and be paid for it so
what are the things that i do on the
weekend right i love um i'm very
involved in the art world i love to go
to museums and galleries but i love to
go see dance and performances because i
want to see how others are interpreting
the world so that inspires me new ideas
new thoughts new ways of looking at the
world are things that interest me
privately and i seek it out and pay
money for it right
so does that mean i have to have a
career in the arts no it means i have to
have a career where new ideas are
explored where people are experimenting
and trying things out and i have to
explore new ideas and try things out and
i'm just as excited to go to work every
day as i am to you know go do something
on a saturday night
and so the idea of finding your passion
is ironically simple because you should
be doing stuff that you enjoy
sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love who
are the people that you love and what
are those what they all have in common
how do you exp decision making um is a
process right the question is what
filters are you using to make decisions
are you making decisions based on the
financial rewards are you making
decisions based on how easy the work
will be i mean i remember in college you
know they would give you this book where
they all the students would rate the
classes and they would rate things like
how easy the class was and how you know
how much you they like the professor and
you know the first year i picked all my
classes based on workload and i picked
everything a low workload you know and
pretty bored
uh didn't work very hard which was fine
but
[Music]
nothing was dynamic and nothing really
excited me and i thank goodness learned
that and so the second year i picked all
my classes by professor raiding
regardless of the workload so every
class i had i had these dynamic amazing
incredible human beings passing on their
knowledge and you were excited to work
hard for them you know um
and so again
the question is what are the filters
we're using and so if you're only
chasing the mighty dollar then you will
have jobs that will pay you a little
more than the last but are you enjoying
yourself and i talked to a guy recently
who was he's in bad shape like he he
really hates his life and he's really
depressed and he doesn't know what to do
and so we were going through all his old
jobs you know and i said give me a job
that you've loved and he hadn't every
single job he's chosen out of college he
picked because of the the money and if
something offered him more somewhere
else he took it
you know regardless and and
and the amazing thing is he plateaued
because if if you're only chasing the
result
if you're only chasing the thing that
makes it easy right
then eventually
you will get bored or they'll get bored
of you right
and you plateau in other words chasing
the almighty dollar if that's your only
thing it eventually flattens out whereas
if you're chasing the thing that excites
you the human beings to be around the
work that excites you the stuff that you
know
you know
you you can get passionate about you
know the the irony is is you'll actually
make way way more right
because you're excited and they
appreciate your excitement and they
reward your excitement and you're better
at your work because you want to work
harder and all of that stuff you don't
have to strain to work harder
so decision making is simply a matter of
filters you know and so i've made
decisions in my life that i would rather
be happy than right i'd rather do good
than
than get rich and and so the decisions i
make um put me in positions where when i
leave any engagement when i leave any
meeting i feel that i've contributed
right um where are the times anymore
where you walk around going
just think of the money just think of
the money think of the money you know um
i i cause it doesn't feel nice and and
the experience i have i don't enjoy
traveling to them and i don't enjoy
traveling home where i have an amazing
experience i am looking forward to
getting there and i'm excited when i
leave
you know so
it's just decision making decision
making is just a matter of what filters
you use and if you're if you're good
about keeping those filters up and clear
then
then make your decisions i don't judge
anybody by how
if they choose to use different filters
these are just the filters i choose to
live my life you know not right or wrong
just those are my decisions how can you
help
the human race
how can you help the human race
the human species
progress
i'm not joking either this is something
i think we all have to be aware of at
the end of the day the human animal is a
social animal
and our very survival depends on our
ability
to form communities to form cultures
what's a community what's a culture it's
a group of people with a common set of
values and beliefs right what's a
country it's a group of people with a
common set of values and beliefs what's
a company it should be a group of people
with a common set of values
and beliefs when we're surrounded by
people who believe what we believe
something remarkable happens
trust emerges
and make no mistake of it trust is a
feeling a distinctly human feeling
you know we we all have friends who are
total screw ups and yet we still trust
them right
trust is not a checklist simply doing
everything you say you're going to do
does not does not mean people will
inherently trust you it just means
you're reliable
we need trust
right we need trust when we're
surrounded by people who believe what we
believe and trust starts to emerge when
we trust them and they trust us we're
more willing to take risks
we're more willing to experiment which
requires failure
we're more willing to explore and go
somewhere that no one has ever gone
before with the confidence
that if we fail if we trip over if we
turn our backs that those within our
community those who we trust and who
trust us will look after us while we're
gone will pick us up when we fall over
we'll help us when we're hurt our very
survival
depends on it
we're not good at everything we're not
good by ourselves you know if i send you
out to go fight a saber-toothed tiger by
yourself odds are tiger one u-0
it's not going to go very well
but if you go out as a group
we're pretty damn amazing and the reason
is is because we all have our strengths
and we all have our certain weaknesses
and the goal is not to fix your
weaknesses the goal is to amplify your
strengths and surround yourself with the
people who can do what you can't do
but it's not just based on skills and
and application and experience it's
based on what you believe
it's based on what you believe you see
simply being good at something and
having somebody else being good at what
you're no good at does not mean you will
trust each other
trust
the sense of trust comes from the sense
of common values and common beliefs
i can prove it
how many of you from new york
okay a bunch of you are you friends with
everybody in new york
why not
why not but when you go to los angeles
and you meet someone from new york
you're like hey i'm from new york and
you're best friends
right and when you go to france you're
there you are on the paris metro minding
your own business
and you hear an american accent behind
you and you turn around you say hey
where you from they say los angeles
you're like hey i'm from new york and
you're best friends
because when you're surrounded by people
who don't believe what you believe when
you're in a strange environment where
you don't feel comfortable you look for
anyone who may share some of the same
values and beliefs that you have and you
start to form a very real and very
intense bond with them simply because
you know that they have a basic
understanding of how you grew up of the
things that you care about of the life
that you live back home
well the same is true when we go to work
do we want to go to work with people who
understand us who believe what we
believe who have a similar view of the
world that has nothing to do with their
opinions and the differences that we
share that's good that's called
diversity that's called advantages to
problem solving which is we can all look
at the same thing from a different angle
and come up with solutions what i'm
talking about is why should you help
each other in the first place what are
you in pursuit of
now the question is is what creates that
sense of values and beliefs what creates
that sense of trust
right our very human instinct we know
how to find people who believe what we
believe our our our survival depends on
it we're biologically gifted with this
idea if i ask you to go out in the
street and find all the people who
believe what you believe you know
exactly what to do you're going to
strike up conversations you're going to
start talking to people and you'll
either you'll have a good feeling about
them or you won't either you'll have
chemistry whatever that means
or you don't sometimes it's quick
sometimes it's slow but we know how to
do it it's called making friends it's
called dating it's called networking we
have the innate ability to do it there
was a former
undersecretary of defense who was
invited to give a speech at a large
conference about a thousand people
and he was standing on the stage with
his cup of coffee
and a styrofoam cup
giving his prepared remarks with his
powerpoint behind him
and he took a sip of his coffee and he
smiled and he looked down at the coffee
and then he went off script
and he said you know last year i spoke
at this exact same conference
last year i was still the undersecretary
and when i spoke here last year they
flew me here business class and when i
arrived at the airport there was
somebody waiting for me to take me to my
hotel
and they took me to my hotel and they
had already checked me in and they just
took me up to my room and the next
morning i came downstairs and there was
someone waiting in the lobby to greet me
and they drove me to this here same
venue they took me through the back
entrance and took me into the green room
and handed me a cup of coffee in a
beautiful ceramic cup
he says i'm no longer the undersecretary
i flew here coach i took a taxi to my
hotel and i checked myself in
when i came down the lobby this morning
i took another taxi to this venue
i came in the front door and found my
way backstage and when i asked someone
do you have any coffee he pointed to the
coffee machine in the corner and i
poured myself a cup of coffee into this
here styrofoam cup
he says the lesson is
the ceramic cup was never meant for me
it was meant for the position i held
i deserve a styrofoam cup
remember this
as you gain fame
as you gain fortune
as you gain position and seniority
people will treat you better they will
hold doors open for you they will get
you a cup of tea and coffee without you
even asking they will call you sir and
ma'am and they will give you stuff
none of that stuff is meant for you
that stuff is meant for the position you
hold
it is meant for the level that you have
achieved of leader or success or
whatever you want to call it
but you will always
deserve
a styrofoam cup
remember that
remember that lesson of humility and
gratitude you can accept all the free
stuff you can accept all the perks
absolutely you can enjoy them but just
be grateful for them and know that
they're not for you
i remember getting off
the acela
i took the acela from new york to
washington dc
and i got off the train like everybody
else and i was walking down the platform
like everyone else and i walked past
general
nordie schwartz
who used to be
the chief of staff of the united states
air force the head of the air force
and here i did you see a guy
in a suit schlepping his own suitcase
down the platform just like me
and just a couple months ago he was
flying on private jets and he had an
entourage and other people carried his
luggage but he no longer held the
position and so now he got to drag his
own suitcase and never did it sort of
remind me more that none of us deserve
the perks that we get we all deserve a
styrofoam cup companies obsess about
their competitors which is fine
tactically which is fine for short term
but long term most companies aren't
brought down by the competition they
know about they're brought down by the
competition they don't know about some
new emerging technology you know do you
think the music business was paying
attention to the computer business at
all of course not they were paying
attention to other music companies
um you know uh
myspace wasn't
focused on friends to uh facebook they
didn't even know facebook existed but
it's facebook that brought them down or
significantly hurt their business
right in other words if you don't even
know who your competitors are what's the
point of fixating and making all of your
business decisions based on competitors
all we're doing is reacting reacting
reacting this is why purpose matters it
gives us a north star yes we have to
concern ourselves with our competition
from a tactical and short-term point of
view but to make long-term strategic
decisions based on a competitive set
that we don't even know that's complete
based on technology that we don't even
know it's it's completely fully baked is
madness it's absolutely madness right so
you want to fixate on the on the the uh
on the path what do leaders need to do
to understand the trends in their
industry better because it's very easy
to say this is where this business or
this is where this competition this
market is going it's actually that's
what everyone else is doing so how can
you get ahead of a trend in the way that
steve jobs was able to look at where the
puck is going so trend data is very
dangerous because all it does is report
a trend it doesn't report if it's
positive or negative and everyone else
has got it and everybody else has got it
so for example you know kids these days
are all using uh apps to do everything
we should make more apps
but nobody says it's healthy
right in the 1980s you needed to do
cocaine to get through the business day
you know does that that's a trend that's
a trend it's not really true cocaine
usage was up in the 1980s
in businesses it was if you worked in an
investment bank yeah yeah yeah no i was
i was i was definitely not doing that so
the point is the point is the point is
it's a trend yeah that doesn't mean we
should invest in it right so trend data
is i think the way people rush towards a
trend because they think that's where
the market is going is very dangerous
because it's incredibly unstable
information but you have to as a leader
anticipate where your market is going
and make three or five year plans and
the way you do it is with vision
right so
for some reason somebody keeps telling
me that i unders my publisher said this
to me that i'm good at understanding the
zeitgeist
uh
and he's wrong i have no clue
about what people are thinking all i
know is where i want to go
that's it
as i said before i have a vision of a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired to go to work feel safe when
they're there and return home fulfilled
at the end of the day so i can make
certain guesses and predictions about
things i have to do to get there the
biggest lesson i learned was thank
goodness i learned it pretty early on
which is
and i think a lot of
business owners make this mistake
um
which is uh because i was the boss you
know in my own mind yeah um uh i thought
i had to know all the answers
and if i didn't i thought i had to
pretend that i did
and
uh
that's stupid
um
and
what i learned is that just because i
may have the the top position in the
hierarchy i i'm not expected to know
everything and if i pretend to know
everything it diminishes the value of
all the great ideas and the great
intelligence around me and when things
got difficult i would never admit it
right i would just put on a brave face
and show up every day and um
and the the biggest lesson i learned was
to say i don't know i don't understand
or i need help
um
at any level about any subject yeah and
amazingly i was always surrounded by
people who wanted to help or who knew
answers but they never offered to help
or offer the answers because they didn't
think i needed it because i kept
pretending that i knew it all right not
to mention the fact that nobody likes a
no at all um
so
that was huge for me and when i was
willing to ask for help and accept it
when it was offered
and and sort of accept the humility of
the fact that other people know a lot
more about a lot of things than i know i
know one thing you know and they know
lots of things
[Music]
that's when things really started to
move because we were now a team like we
were actually working together i see a
lot of questions here around dealing
with a negative team or dealing with a
team where we feel people may not have
the right intentions or the right
motives how do people work with that the
viewers are asking yeah it happens um
and the answer is don't worry about it
like we can't obsess about the ones that
are doing something wrong we obsess
about the ones that are doing something
right instead of criticizing the ones
that are negative we want to build up
and complement the ones that are
positive
because when that's the reward structure
which is finding and identifying and
rewarding good
then everybody wants to be rewarded and
recognized and so eventually the
behavior comes in as opposed to
criticizing wrong nobody wants to be
criticized and all it does is it makes
people back away and afraid so the point
is ignore the negativity and focus on
the positivity and start obsessing about
the people that are doing something
right i learned this lesson the hard way
i wrote a blog and we had a uh uh
somebody write in with a very aggressive
sort of note to me and sort of saying
i'm a hypocrite and all of this stuff
and my team got together and we
discussed our response and somebody
wrote back and he rebecca very nicely
responds back and we thought okay how do
we react to this and i eventually got on
the phone with him and tried to talk
with him and they talked him off the
shelf and talking about the you know was
okay and about six months later i wrote
another blog and he wrote another and we
got together and it occurred to us we
were spending all of this time with one
negative person and we were ignoring
all of the people who wrote in
compliments and were supporting our work
and so we literally made a decision that
day that when we got results like that
we wouldn't care and that if we were
going to invest any time of our people
it was going to be to say thank you to
the people who were helping us and
helping compliment us and helping
advance the message and so we don't i
personally don't respond to those at all
anymore ever but i
regularly call people up to say thank
you for helping advance the cause and it
feels nicer was steve jobs playing the
finite game because he was crushing the
competition or was he playing the
infinite game because he just did his
own thing
so
jobs had a very clear vision
and it was to give the individual the
power to stand up to big brother he was
at his heart
a rebel he grew up in
northern california
during the vietnam war which was the
where the beginning of the
anti-establishment revolution sort of
started yeah and that was his childhood
um and so he really he really stood for
the individual standing up to
to to the man and he had a big spiritual
side he was a buddhist at times yeah
and if you look at the decisions he made
he made decisions like this he ran
decisions through his vision before he
got to the interests right
so there's a very famous story
of when he went to xerox park do you
know this one
so jobs they just come up the success of
the apple one and the apple ii it's
already a big company he's already well
known it's a it's he's already the
darling of business
and uh their next big push is going to
be into a technology they called the
lisa that was their next computer
that they were going to launch and just
as executives do they visit each other's
companies and jobs and a few of his
colleagues went to visit xerox park
and xerox showed them a new technology
that they had invented called the
graphic user interface
right
now
remember jobs believed in the individual
standing up to big brother so the reason
they made their computers beautiful was
not arbitrary
it's because if you had them if they
were pretty looking you'd put them in
the living room if they're ugly you put
them in the basement
and you're more likely to use something
that's in the living room than if it's
in the basement
right
the reason you make them simple is
because more people can then use them
and so when he saw this thing called the
graphic user interface he thought this
is a better technology
it's a leapfrog to make it easier for
more individuals to access the power of
the personal computer
than what we have in the lisa so that's
an infinite game because he's thinking
about what's right for the long term
rather than what his competition and as
they left dirk park job says we have to
invest in this
and his colleagues said we're you're
crazy we've
invested millions of dollars millions of
man hours already in the lisa if we do
this
if we invest in this we're going to blow
up our own company to which jobs replied
better we should blow it up than someone
else
that decision became the mac the
macintosh that decision was the
macintosh
of which remember windows
is an interface designed to copy the
macintosh in other words he completely
changed the way computers work to the
point where now any individual can
easily use
a computer and he always made decisions
that way
he made decisions always empowering the
individual so he was asked
um
a question about the
movie industry cinemas and the decline
of cinemas
and he replied that the the cinemas were
making the same mistake the movie
industry was making the same mistake
that the music industry made which is
the music industry falsely believed that
their customer was tower records and
virgin mega store
and not the person who actually spent
money on buying the album
he says you've confused your customer
with you with your distribution channel
i was boarding a flight and the scene
played out in front of me
where one of the passengers attempted to
board the plane before their group
number was called
and the gate agent uh literally berated
him sir step aside i haven't called your
group please step aside and wait till i
call your group
so i spoke up and said why do you have
to talk to us that way why can't you
talk to us like we're human beings
and she looked me in the eye and said if
i don't follow the rules i could get in
trouble or lose my job
all she revealed to me is that she
doesn't feel safe in her own company and
her leaders do not trust her to do the
job for which he's been trained to do
and guess who suffers us and the company
the reason we love flying southwest
airlines is because the company trusts
them to do the job they've been trained
to do and they use discretion we don't
trust people to follow the rules we
trust people to know when to break them
and the problem is in a fear-based
society people fear for their own jobs
more than common sense
that was a perfectly
a perfect scenario of what happens when
somebody in the company is too afraid
to break the rule break the policy use
discretion find another way
you know
so
almost predictable that something will
happen something will break at some
point how would someone know if they're
doing something for their why how do you
know oh you can feel it you feel it you
ever had that experience where um you
feel like
something's wrong yeah you know sort of
you're like you make a decision but it
makes you uncomfortable you're not
you're not following through with your
cause or your purpose and you ever have
a decision where everybody's like you're
crazy you're crazy like this just feels
like the most natural normal thing i
could do i'm not even in doubt here you
know right now the problem with simply
running on gut is it's not scalable this
is the reason we want to learn our why
learn to articulate and be able to speak
our why so that others can understand
why we're making the decisions we're
making because the problem is if you
only trust your gut to those around you
sometimes it does appear that we're
crazy or unfocused and so people leave
us and don't help us because they think
we're nuts
the minute we can articulate and speak
that why with clarity that others can
understand then not only will they have
context for the decisions we're making
but they'll rally to help us and even do
things that we didn't even ask because
they understand
the higher purpose that we're trying to
advance so
you just know it's a terrible answer um
but you can feel it and this is where
joy and fulfillment in our work come
from which is different from happiness
you can win a big client get a promotion
get a raise happy you know do a good job
produce something great happy but that
feeling dissipates it doesn't last for
you know it certainly doesn't last for
months or years it might last for days
or weeks right that that immensely happy
feeling that we all have that big client
we won or that big promotion we got is
now gone
joy fulfillment which doesn't mean that
we love every day but joy and
fulfillment comes from that feeling that
every day our work is contributing to
something bigger and that's that's way
more important infinite game exists up
here
finite game exists down here
right the infinite game is
includes the why what i call our purpose
cause or belief
it's the vision of the company it's
where we're going it's something that we
will never practically reach in our
lifetimes or ever
but we will die trying that's the point
right it's different from a big hairy
audacious goal which for all practical
purposes you could reach it may be
difficult but you could reach it this is
an ideal something it's a vision of the
world so my vision i imagine a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired to go
to work feel safe when they're there and
return home fulfilled at the end of the
day that is my vision
right
we will never practically get there but
we will die trying the united states was
founded with a document called the
declaration of independence in which the
document stated all men are created
equal
now the united states has not achieved
that and will never achieve that but it
the country is at its best when we're
trying to achieve that civil rights
women's suffrage gay rights the you know
universal education universal healthcare
etc etc
this is where our values
exist our values are timeless they do
not change every year whenever we have a
strategic offsite and if they do you
have a problem
that happens in big companies
every few years a new ceo comes in and
they have a values thing and they change
and they change and they change no no
your values are your values right
and they're based on your founders
and they exist
from patterns
uh of how you operate when you are
operating at your natural best when your
company is operating at its natural best
when all cylinders are firing when
you're in the flow whatever euphemism
you want to use there is a pattern that
emerges and that pattern are your values
there's a minimum of three there's no
more than five if there's more than five
there's usually redundancy you can find
overlap that you can find lowest common
denominators and they are intractable
these things are inherently intangible
and hard to measure
right
which is why they often get brushed
aside it's not that they don't exist
they're just hard to measure
then down here you have the fine it's
what i call the what it's all the
tangible stuff
right things like our interests
exist down here because they are
tangible they are inherently easy to see
and easy to measure like products sold
money taken in things like that right
number of clients we have
the way you build an infinite business
is you want to run all decisions first
through your values and your cause and
then through your interests i've become
very very interested in the idea
of
playing in games that have no finish
lines
right
some games have finish lines
right baseball football right
um
getting a part is the finish line you
audition
there's a beginning middle and end
there's rehearsal and practice
there's uh uh
uh showing up for the audition and you
either win or you lose and then it's
over
it's over right that is finite
but one's career
is infinite
there's there's no end it's like our
lives are finite but life is infinite
people come and people go but life
continues right theater actors come and
actors go but theater continues it's
infinite you don't win theater
you win a part
but what happens once you get the part
the the finite game is over now you
enter the infinite game you have to be
able to convert right and the reason
this is important and i've seen this
unfortunately so many times from a young
age all you wanted to do was get to
broadway
and then you get to broadway
and then what you've devoted your entire
life to one finite goal and when you get
there the immediate response is
depression
because i i spent
15 years of my life for this one thing
and i got it
and now i don't know what to do next
like what a
get to broadway again
it doesn't have the same
ambition
it doesn't have the same passion
you know you've devoted you're from you
know you're from fargo north dakota and
that's all you wanted to do is get out
of fargo and make it to broadway and you
made it
right it doesn't have the same kind of
passion and this is because these are
finite goals
there's a lot of
studies that have been done
with
athletes who have finite goals
to become the greatest ex in the world
right so andre agassi was one of these
one of these athletes he wanted to
become the greatest tennis player that
ever lived guess what
everyone in his life he would he would
view them through how do you help me get
to that
everything was how does this help me get
to that everything was a transaction to
how do you help me move to there and
then you know what happens he achieved
it he became the greatest tennis player
in the world and you know what happened
immediately after
depression
michael phelps
set out to become the most meddled
olympian in history you know what he
achieved it you know what happened
immediately after
depression
they spend their whole life working for
one goal
though most will never get it the few
that do
don't know what to do next because their
goals were finite
their goals were finite
right and so
there are finite components to your
career
but your career should be infinite
so yes of course you have to win the
finite game you have to get the part but
immediately when you get the part now
you convert to infinite military we're
willing to sacrifice ourselves for the
gain of others right but in business
we're willing to sacrifice others for
our own gain yes
how do you build that military mindset
in companies like here or other
companies leadership
i mean it's it's leadership creates an
environment and it's i mean this is what
i learned the the the whole concept of
leaders eat last and those lessons that
i learned from spending time with folks
in uniform
it was born out of my own experience
where i i was going through a point in
my career as my career was growing all
of a sudden you have new friends that i
didn't have before
and and that's wonderful and then i
learned the hard way that they weren't
my friends they were playing me they
wanted access or a deal or something
right and i and i i learned it the hard
way and so i retreated i was like i
wanted to be friends with nobody else
but the people i knew way back when
which is also not a good way to live
and yet simultaneously i'm spending time
with tons of folks in the military who
you know in business we have colleagues
and co-workers in the military of
brothers and sisters and that's a
different kind of relationship and as
you know i have hugged more people in
uniform than i've ever hugged in suits
i've cried with more people in uniform
than i've ever cried with in suits i've
stood in the audience and listened to
officers give talks and i've sat in the
audience and cried i've never cried with
any ceo game
gave a speech ever right
so there's a different nature of
relationship and my original conclusion
was they're better people
that the reason you get a
disproportionate amount of these kinds
of behaviors is because they're better
people and better people are drawn to a
life of service in the military which is
why we find a disproportionately high
number of them there and the more i
started to learn the more i realized i
was completely wrong
it's the environment
it's the environment and when the leader
creates an environment in which people
feel that someone has my back they will
do extraordinary things and what i
learned is that courage is not this deep
down internal fortitude
right it comes externally it's like a
trapeze artist would never try a brand
new death defying act unless they had a
net
the courage didn't come from
the trapeze artist the courage came from
the net and it's the same in
the military which is especially when
you're in life and death situations when
you're when you're when you're in
theater
people who you don't like you still rely
on to save your life and the reason it
works is because you don't have to look
behind your shoulder
and that mentality and you know better
than anybody which is
when you when you are deployed into
dangerous places
nobody sort of loves deployment but
people have warm feelings towards
deployment which is really strange and
suicides rarely happen in in combat
situations they usually happen back home
and it's the intensity of the
relationships that create that warmth
and the sort of weird enjoyment of
really bad uncomfortable and dangerous
circumstances it's because this we're
human beings and human beings as social
animals
feel our safest
when we trust each other and good
leaders are capable of producing that so
great businesses look very much like
well-run military organizations and you
know those poorly around military
organizations as well but great
businesses look exactly the same where
the
leaders give the glory they distribute
authority they push it down the ranks
let people make decisions if they screw
up there's no risk of getting fired if
the company misses its arbitrary
projections on its arbitrary date we do
not use the people to balance the books
we figure out other ways or we even
invite the people to help solve the
problems
these are the things that produce that
circle of safety that produce the exact
same outcome where people will love each
other cry for each other sacrifice for
each other you see it in business plenty
but it always boils down
to leadership
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there